Okay. Before we get in too much further into this, we should actually
talk about what we're doing so this class is going to have two lessons.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Lesson one is on HTML and CSS, which are basically, how
does this webpage work or how does it look, I should say.
>> Yeah and then, lesson two will be on
the JavaScript, which is sort of more how, how
it works, how, the elements on the page are
controlled, how, things change when you interact with the page.
>> Right and
so if you're an experienced programmer with a
decent amount of experience who doesn't wan to
learn the basics of HTML and CSS, you can go ahead and skip to, lesson two.
>> But it would still be super valuable to have you in
the forums, since the new programmers
will definitely benefit from your knowledge.
>> Yeah. Nothing like having some experienced help
around, like Sarah, to help you in programming.